Half a million more Russian fighters.
That's what Ukraine is bracing
for tonight.
500,000 more Russians
and a major onslaught.
Here's Ukraine's defense minister
with the chilling warning
if you'd seen those.
Officially, they announced 300,000.
I know since I saw me.
But when we see
the troops at the borders,
the two are so massive.
According to our estimates,
it is much more declared war so minimal,
we think that they have
already mobilized 500,000
500,000.
It sounds huge.
An absolute basis.
And if it pans out, it is huge.
Just to give you the context,
500,000 is nearly two and a half times
more than the number of Russian
fighters used to invade Ukraine
nearly one year ago.
And the predicted new offensive
could be just weeks away.
In the
past, we
think that
given that they love symbolism,
they will try
something around February 24th
February 24th, of course, marks one year
since the beginning of Putin's
invasion of Ukraine.
And as Ukraine braces
for what could be this massive onslaught,
the nuclear drumbeat again
growing louder in Russia.
Just listen to
what's being said tonight on Russian TV.
If the media this ends with our victory
or the sense
in a nuclear world war three,
the defense minister of Ukraine is saying
that Russia's already mobilized
500,000 soldiers,
that they're seeing them
amass on these borders again.
Do you think that we're about
to see a big change in this war?
Well, I really don't.
I think we may see a big change
in this war in a couple of months.
But as the soldiers
said, this is very much like World
War Two.
No.
In fact,
this is like World
War One, the trench warfare in France
That went on for years and years.
Unfortunately, I think
in the
near term,
we're going to see much the same
for the next couple of months
until one side of the other prepares
for a counteroffensive.
That's why we got the tanks.
That's why we're bringing in the tanks.
So the Ukrainians have a chance.
And the Russians
may have plans on the road
but I certainly hope
we're interdicting their lines
to make sure the majority troops
never show up.
Ekaterina, you pointed out to us
that sound bite we played of sort of the
the most prominent Russian state
media, television anchor.
Right.
Threatening that if the Russians don't
win, it's nuclear World War three.
And you're
pointing out that a lot of the Putin
TV commentators on state
media are backing more action.
They really are upping the rhetoric
right now.
Let me play how another
prominent TV host put it
not enough
talk about this without a third.
Why would our state build up
a stockpile
of strategic
and tactical nuclear missiles?
You hear why
some
just to be afraid of using them
Kerry.
What do you read into that?
And what does the Russian
public really think at this point?
This was Vladimir Solovyov,
one of the biggest stars
of Russian propaganda.
Aaron, actually, the situation right now
is dangerous for Vladimir Putin.
As we can see, they don't have any other
any other tools to use
for the Russian public
and for the Western world,
except for the threats
they are threatening the world
with this World War
three, with the nuclear weapon,
because this is the last hope
that they can catch right now.
And over the world,
the attitude of people in Russia is
is fear
actually
that society is terribly depressed.
People understand
that this is the war, actually,
that this is not
a special military operation,
how they called it before.
Vladimir Putin is already calling this
a war
and Sergei Lavrov,
the minister for foreign affairs
and others,
they are not hiding anymore
that this is a very serious situation
and people
are understanding it right now.
So this is the new stage
for Russian society
and they can hear this words
about the nuclear weapon.
I know that people are scared to death.
They don't want this nuclear war,
of course,
because they don't want to die.
They want to,
you know, raise their children and so on.
And so forth.
So they are looking for some kind of,
you know, maybe a kind and soft moment.
There are looking forward
to maybe freezing this this war,
because this is the only way to survive
for Russian citizens.
They don't know how to see the future
with outside of Putin
because he has built
a terrible, repressive state
where no one
has the right to think freely
or to talk freely, as you know.
So, General Kimmitt,
you know, a well-known
and highly respected
Russian analyst,
said this about the current state
of the Russian military
in the context of what
Ekaterina just said. Here it is.
Yes.
And I believe
that by
the start of the mobilization,
our airborne forces lost
40 to 50% of the staff.
Look, it's
an incredible admission, right,
happening on one of those
very same programs. General.
So I do want to emphasize that.
But to say something
like that, that nearly half
of Russia's airborne forces are gone,
I mean, it's stunning
but then I think about what
the Ukrainian defense minister
said today,
that Russia has 500,000
more soldiers coming.
General, what is the real picture here?
Well,
I think the real picture is
quantity has a quality all its own.
If they are going to be pouring
500,000 troops
and that's going to make
a significant difference
no matter how many tanks we give,
no matter how much artillery they have.
But I wouldn't put too much stock
in what the defense minister said.
There's an old saying military
that first report is usually wrong.
And that seems like
an awfully large number
to anybody
that's been following this for some time.
It certainly does.
I mean, you heard it today and said,
wait a minute,
it wasn't
the math that we'd heard
of the mobilization or anything.
But but it is a stunning number.
Catarina, you have extensively covered
Putin. Opposition Leader Alexei Navalny.
He is in the news today.
His lawyer
saying that he is being transferred
to even harsher solitary confinement.
He, of course, is the opposition leader
in Russia.
And was poisoned by Putin's men
and then put into a penal colony.
Sometimes he's able
to pass messages to his team
and then they post them on Twitter today.
That happened
and this was posted quote,
When something like this happens to you,
you realize how important it is
to fight
this unscrupulous regime,
how important it is to do
just about anything in order
to throw the yoke of these scoundrels off
Russia and dispel
the illusion that they have planted
in the heads of millions.
Let us try to remain strong
and do all we can every day.
And yet he physically seems weaker
every time we get an image of him.
Ekaterina and I said today,
going to even harsher
solitary confinement.
What happens if he doesn't survive?
It's going to be a huge problem for him
because he has already tried to kill him,
and we know that.
But it was a different time right now
when the level of fear
and depression
in Russian society is so high,
when everyone is at the edge,
when mobilization is
something that people are scared
very much
and you know,
we know that because we can see how much
how many people watch us.
And millions of Russians
are asking questions
about mobilization in particular.
So Navalny knee his death if it happens,
I mean, it's terrible, but if it happens,
can be a huge trigger
for Russian people
to go out on the streets and to protest
and to change something.
I don't want this to happen, of course,
and no one wants this to happen
and Putin doesn't want it to happen.
So that's why
they're not killing him in jail.
This is the only good news
for Alexei Navalny and for the
for the civil society
of Russian Federation,
which survives out of Russia.
Unfortunately, right now.
So, yes,
he's in a terrible circumstances.
They're trying to break his personality,
his stamina,
but he's proving every single day.
Erin, if you look at him
and if you look what he says,
what he writes,
what he tweets
with the help of his lawyers,
you can see how strong this person is.
And I'm sure that he survives, actually.
Catarina, thank you very much.
General Kimmitt, thanks to you.